aujourd'hui je vais partir à la
recherche d'une mosquée à Paris on parle
souvent de la région musulmane seulement
la violence et la haine et c'est pas
forcément ce que je crois et c'est comme
ça que les gens justifient le fait qu'il
faut pas que j'aille dans une mosquée
parce que c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
pour moi comparé à une église j'ai vu
qu'il y a une mosquée à côté de la tour
Eiffel à Paris qui est l'une des plus
connu d'ailleurs je vais aller voir pour
m'y rendre voici mon autre suite
incognito pour sortir dans la rue ok ça
passe OK j'ai trouvé une mosquée
purée c'est fermé j'arriverai à
comprendre au planning je vais essayer
de comprendre tout ça je reviendrai
quand ce sera ouvert j'ai fait toute
cette route pour rien
alors benjamination
et je pense pas que j'en ai commis et je
pense que j'ai plus envie de
de monde
je reviens pas en arrière et cherche pas
qu'on oublie non
Momo
votre collègue
cnews Pascal
mes mémoires pour me dire la pédophilie
j'ai dit j'ai dit il faut chercher à
comprendre pourquoi on devient vous
étiez venu ici nous voir exactement
[Rires]
[Musique]
forcément ça me choque autant de croyant
parce que je sais que derrière tout ça
il y a des croyants ça peut aussi
heurter des millions par des milliers de
personnes
je vais te mettre une baffe ou quoi ou
quoi non
si tu veux visiter le mosquée tu es
toujours le bienvenu tu seras toujours
le bienvenu mais il y a des règles à
respecter il faut de la pudeur du
respect et d'humilité tu vois si tu
arrives à avoir ces trois qualités en
toi viens je te prends la main on y va
tous les deux et tu vas voir un petit
peu le monde qui est autour du culte que
ça soit dans une église ou dans une dans
une synagogue si je peux me permettre
quand tu veux dans une mosquée viens on
va t'accueillir comme des grands frères
peu importe ton orientation sexuelle
nous regarde pas ça peu importe ta vie
ok nous on laisse à l'extérieur tu viens
tu rentres tu viens tu rentres Benjamin
on te donne la main on te montre ce que
c'est ce que c'est que l'islam ce que
c'est que les musulmans et c'est pas
forcément ce que tu vois la télé le
musulman
et il s'en fout de tout en fait
[Musique]
l'attitude
[Applaudissements]
toutes ces vidéos
évidemment je suis tellement désolé pour
vos parents
[Applaudissements]
répondez mais du coup
de la violence
avec la violence verbale de Bernard
Bernard Montiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]